[Music]
much ado about nothing yes uh
you're this is uh
great play of course by william
shakespeare were you reluctant to take
on that feels like a challenge and
you're a terrific actor but it must be
intimidating to to to to make a movie
that was written by shakespeare rule
number one when joss whedon calls you
and says hey would you like to you just
say yes
then i saw the material and i got to
tell you it's not easy shakespeare it's
not i never would have thought it would
be it feels like when you watch an actor
do shakespeare it feels like this would
be difficult to master there's a trick i
mean because they trick you it's english
you figure oh i know english
no
i like that face we just did to each
other i don't know why just
this you know what this is going to be
an internet meme
[Applause]
i want you to come back and i want to do
a whole segment where we just do mems
[Applause]
did i mention we're idiots here at the
show
uh well you uh you know what uh you uh
you do you're such a terrific actor you
do a terrific job we have a clip here
from much ado about nothing should we
take a look let's do
come find them
i'm naughty fart wait you are an ass
you are an ass
does that not respect my place
does that not suspect my years
[Music]
oh
that you were here to write me down an
ass
butt masters remember that i am an ass
though
it be not written down yet forget not
that i am an ass
[Applause]